it was like you know an alien spacecraft
landing in the middle of Jerusalem
here's a stone with an inscription that
is actually quoted from the Jewish Bible
and that proves that a Jewish temple
actually stood in Jerusalem here is a
proof that our national heritage is it
can be basically now we can touch it we
can we can smell it we can go see it we
can think all children this is where we
came from the Israel Antiquities
Authority urgently wanted to know how
the owner whoever he was had come by
such an artifact of national and
historical importance Amir ganor the
authority's chief investigator pumped
his contacts in the market for
information he suspected it had been
illegally looted
but the word on the street told a
different story as journalists Boesky on
soon discovered I traveled to Jerusalem
and started to dig and try and find out
who the owner of this new tablet is and
the people in the antique industry who
who you know do not like to expose their
their identity was they told me the
straightaway that they think it's a hoax
whether it was a hoax or loot or their
genuine article
American or was determined to track down
the owner and the tablet itself which
had now disappeared again
he had many rumors to follow but it
would take a long time to get a clear
picture for the old public the months of
detective work finally led him to Tel
Aviv with Israel's modern commercial
capital and in a fashionable residential
quarter to the home of a businessman one
of Israel's leading antiquity collectors
Oded Golan
the land has been collecting ancient
artifacts since he was a boy here you
are looking now at the oldest the most
ancient dictionary ever found in the
world I found it when I was 10 years old
he admitted he'd been helping to sell
the missing stone tablet but denied that
he had ever been its owner
he was a dealer Palestinian dealer who
had a shop in East Jerusalem Abu Yasser
was his nickname I didn't have enough
money to buy it and they asked me if I
can help him to sell it or to offering
to somebody and I had actually only one
condition it should stay in a museum for
the public 700 thousands of dollars but
the authorities weren't convinced by the
story and what made them highly
suspicious was that the same collector
Oded Golan had recently been involved in
another sensational discovery which has
suddenly appeared